just taking a taking a sip for my John
Wayne mug that's uh you know it says
here on the back a man's got to have a
code a Creed to live by and that is that
is very good advice good advice from the
Duke and I'm I'm a huge fan I'm a big
big John Wayne fan I've seen almost all
of his movies and I love all of them
especially you know The Searchers True
Grit the man who shot Liberty valance
quiet man I mean the classics these are
classic films but the big news is that
I'm not allowed to like John Wayne
anymore I probably shouldn't be drinking
out of this cup it's an offensive cup I
should probably be throwing it and
smashing it on the ground in anger and
you're not allowed to like him either
in case you didn't know John Wayne is
yet another dead man who has been
posthumously excommunicated from polite
society why well well seemingly
seemingly at random seemingly is the key
word there I'll go back to this the
seemingly part but seemingly at random a
yesterday an interview with that John
Wayne did with playboy in 1971 went
viral so yes this is a this is a 50 year
old interview a famous interview I might
add an interview that is not exactly
secret it's not like this thing was dug
up like it had been buried in the desert
like the Gnostic Gospels or something
for 2,000 years and then it was dug up
and found no it's been it's been out
there I mean he did it in Playboy so
people knew about it but it was it was
it went viral half a century later fifty
years after it was published and forty
years after John Wayne died has died and
leftists on Twitter were taking
screenshots of the various portions of
the exchange that John Wayne had with
Playboy and posting them online and
exclaiming over what a racist and and
and what a sexist John Wayne was because
he says a bunch of racist sexist stuff
in this interview and they were so
shocked they said oh my gosh
what a piece of garbage John Wayne was
and yes you know what John Wayne was a
racist he says some legitimately racist
things in that interview there's there's
no question about it for for some reason
yesterday it was important that everyone
acknowledge the the racism of this dead
Hollywood actor and boldly condemned it
we have to boldly stand up against John
Wayne and said John Wayne you racist
condemned the opinions of a man who has
been dead since the Carter
Administration now I said this interview
when went viral and this anti John Wayne
backlash was seemingly random but not
really random though there is a method
behind this madness for the left there
is a point to it this is part of a
larger strategy a larger plan us in the
plan is to sort of systematically go
back through history find people who
white males today might like or admire
from history might consider to be
personal heroes or what have you and dig
up their skeletons you know dig up the
the scale or dig out the skeletons in
their closet even as their actual
skeletons are decomposing in the grave
that's the that's the plan and the point
behind this is that white males of today
are not allowed to look back in history
and admire or enjoy the work of other
white males that's the point you're not
allowed to do that our heroes must be
culturally approved we can admire women
from history we can admire minorities
from history but not too much keep in
mind not to visibly because that would
be cultural appropriation so we
basically we're not allowed to have any
heroes we can't really have you can't
have white males because they're all bad
but even someone who's not a white male
well you can't like them too
much because if you do then it's like
you're trying to steal heroes from other
racial groups so that's the that's the
point and the only way I think to
respond to these posthumous smear
campaigns is to have utter contempt for
them contempt for the smear campaigns
not for the people who are being smeared
and when the left comes to you saying
aren't you gonna condemn this guy who
had this bad opinion a long time ago
aren't you gonna stand up with us and
condemn him you know what our answer
should be our answer should be no hey
you know what I'm not going to get out
of my face I'm not gonna play your game
I don't care John Wayne had racist
opinions you know what I'm gonna watch
his movies anyway I still like him
I'm gonna watch I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go on a John Wayne movie watching binge
this weekend and I'm gonna have my kids
watch the movies too and I'm gonna tell
them this is John Wayne he was a great
actor you kids should like him - that's
what I'm gonna do because I'm not gonna
play your game I don't care I I'm not
gonna dance to your music when you
randomly decide that nope not allowed to
like John Wayne anymore no well I still
do I I don't care well how can you like
him use racist you're not supposed on't
you understand that that's the I don't
care it doesn't matter to me yes John
Wayne was racist that's true
John Wayne was born in 1907 you utter
nincompoops do you know who else was
racist literally everybody born in 1907
or earlier not every white male mind you
okay but every person in the world with
very few exceptions if any I mean I
can't even think of what an exception
would be maybe there are a few but
almost everybody born in the world
in 1907 or earlier would be
considered racist by our standards today
here is one thing that I could say for
absolute certain anyone born from the
beginning of human civilization to about
1950 would have held without question
and without exception views and opinions
that we would find a portent today
whether those a lot of the time those
views are gonna be on issues like race
and ethnicity and culture or the views
could be on gender or the views could be
about homosexuals okay
but everybody born from the beginning of
human civilization to approximately 1950
is going to have opinions on some or all
of those subjects that we today would
find would find repulsive so we could
give the John Wayne treatment to anyone
of either gender of any race of any
ethnicity because you see the idea that
all races are equal and that we
shouldn't be suspicious of people who
don't look like us okay this is the
right idea this is a good idea it's a
true idea it's morally correct it's
morally upstanding yes but it's also a
very new idea and and you know what else
it's a very Western idea and I'm gonna
put a serious emphasis on Western
because if you go to many non-western
countries even today you're going to
find that many of the inhabitants still
do not share our progressive enlightened
views on race and probably on gender and
almost certainly on sexual orientation
even today you're gonna find that in
many non-western countries do you think
you're gonna find a lot of racial
enlightenment in the Middle East the
answer is No
you're going back through history then
you're gonna reach a certain point you
know if you're going back in your time
machine if you're going back with your
scolding finger to go scold people back
in history who didn't share your views
on race views that again yes are correct
and all right so congratulations to you
and to all of us but if you're going
back to scold you're gonna be doing a
lot of scolding you'll be spending a lot
of time you I hope you gassed up your
time machine because you've got to go
you've got a lot of you've got a lot of
driving to do or flying or however your
time machine travels you see what the
left wants us to do is they want us to
look at history through a modern-day
lens but very selectively okay so we are
meant to hold only certain people almost
always white males to the moral
standards of today not always whitened I
mean there are sometimes white women
will get this treatment too Laura
Ingalls Wilder was one of the other
recent people to be posthumously
posthumously defrocked essentially
because she did not have enlightened
opinions about about race apparently and
so the trick is is is to convince us
that that these people who the left
chooses don't deserve the benefit of
historical context and the way that they
did it's really important for us to
understand the way that this is done
okay the way that they do this is by
conflating personal moral guilt with
objective moral wrong now those are not
the same thing okay in this
something that relativists get wrong
also there is objective moral look wrong
and then there is personal moral guilt
so wrong is wrong I totally agree with
that bad is bad wrong is wrong always
end forever
what's wrong today was wrong in 1907 it
was wrong in 1807 it was wrong in 1207
it's been wrong since time immemorial
so the racism that was prevalent across
the planet until very recently was wrong
definitely totally wrong and but the
problem is that the left says because it
was wrong that means that all of those
racists people well the white males
anyway war pieces of garbage whose
statue should be torn down and their
movies should be burned in a giant
bonfire and so on you see that's the
leap they make they start for a premise
we can agree with which is racism is
wrong fine yeah
racism is wrong today it was wrong at
any other point in history yes I agree
but then they doing another move and
they say therefore all of these racist
people were terrible and do not deserve
our admiration and do not deserve to be
remembered or honored or anything like
that but no see that that equation
doesn't work that's it that's a fallacy
the badness of the individual it depends
on personal moral guilt not just on the
on the objective moral wrong of the
action or the viewpoint or whatever
we're talking about but on personal
moral guilt so everybody that does a
wrong thing or holds a morally wrong
view does have some moral guilt for it
no matter when and where they hold that
view but that guilt can be mitigated it
can be severely mitigated in some cases
depending on context that's where
context matters and the context that
everybody in the world lived in from the
beginning of human civilization until
the middle of the 20th century is one
where Outsiders where people who looked
different who had a different call
they were in some sense inferior and
worthy of suspicion this is the context
that almost everybody throughout history
lived in and admit you know they lived
amid this this this context pretty much
everywhere in the world that doesn't
make it right but it does mean that it's
much much easier to slip into a wrong
view when the wrong view is totally
normal and taken for granted and
everybody holds it and that's just the
way things are that's the that's you
know people will generally accept as
normal and as right the the context that
they're born into now our situation is
different because it's been drilled into
our heads from birth that racism is an
abomination we have we have been told
this over and over and over and over
again since we were very small children
so we get no credit the fact that you're
racially enlightened that doesn't you
get no credit for that you can't pat
yourself on the back or congratulate
yourself for that you didn't choose that
view okay it's not like you were born in
the in the 1500s and you came to this
conclusion on your own in that case I
would say you deserve a lot of credit
but you don't deserve any credit for
this you were told this and you accepted
it so so fine good it's good that you
accepted it but that's all to be not
racist in our context all that means is
that you just have to accept what you're
told and what everybody else believes
and and and and you know it's it's a
base not only the normal view but it's
but to hold any other view is is is is
roundly condemned and we'll get you
rejected from society and which is all
good and fine that it should be
condemned but the point is to accept
that doesn't take any courage on your
part doesn't take any enlightenment that
doesn't take any intelligence it's just
it's just normal
you see the test for us these days is is
not whether we're racist because most of
us are not racist
and so non racism is just taken for
granted but in our culture as as in any
culture there are other viewpoints there
are other really wrong beliefs and
practices that are relatively normal to
us racism is not one of them but there
are others there are other forms of
discrimination even that we take for
granted so the test for us is whether we
can see those and condemn those is
whether we can see outside of our own
context to see the the objective wrong
of something that a lot of us just
accept but here's the interesting thing
that almost without fail the people who
shame those from the past for their very
limited very stuck in the culture
beliefs those people today are also
guilty of themselves guilty themselves
of holding those same kinds of beliefs
not on matters of race but in other
areas and so the main one that comes to
mind is the pro-abortion belief you know
being pro-abortion today is is is he's
relatively normal it's certainly
culturally acceptable and it's just
something that a lot of people buy into
because that's the situation that they
were born that's the situation they were
born into now a hundred years from now I
can pretty much guarantee you that
people are gonna look back on on
abortion and if your abortion supporters
are gonna look at people like you and
they're gonna say what a piece of
garbage how could you have accepted this
what you thought babies weren't people
guy they're killing a million babies a
year and you were fine with what is
wrong with you
you see if you support abortion you're
gonna be that's that's how history is
going to remember you
and in fact you have a lot less of an
excuse than a sort of everyday racist
that you came across in 1907 or in any
other point you know you have a lot less
of an excuse because because today
abortion is at least a contentious issue
I mean there are millions of people who
have who do see the truth of it and
they're trying to convince you of it and
they're telling you and so in order for
you to continue in your beliefs you have
to block all of that out but for a long
time in history there was it was all
basically nobody had a non racist belief
that that was an opinion that nobody
held it just wasn't represented by
anyone I mean you go back even to the to
the abolitionists in in the mid 19th
century and they were they were
progressive for their time but they
weren't non racist you know I've been
I've been waiting for the day when when
liberals discover the the
lincoln-douglas debates you know where
Abraham Lincoln famously made some very
racist remarks he was against slavery so
he deserves credit for that but he was
definitely racist he was a white
supremacist he just didn't think he just
he could see enough to see the rate that
the slavery was wrong but he didn't see
anything wrong with racism in and of
itself so even the people who are who
were enlightened for their time back as
recently as the mid 19th century were
still by our standards hugely racist
so that just puts it an even more
context puts more of a perspective
something like abortion on the other
hand has there's always been millions of
people who reject that
so in our culture it has never been
normal to the extent that something like
racism was normal everywhere in the
world for much of human history but
that's the test so
you know rather than focusing on John
Wayne maybe and this is something we can
all do rather than going back in history
and digging up these people and shouting
at their corpses and condemning them
maybe look within yourself and and do a
survey of your own heart your own soul
your own mind to think about the beliefs
that you hold and that you take for
granted and and try to discover if
there's if there if there are any
beliefs that you now hold and take for
granted because they're normal which in
fact may be morally atrocious I think
that would be a better use of our time
all right um let's see here I've got
okay I've got to get to this story
because it's it's just it's just crazy
and it's a perfect it it's a basically a
parable about the incompetence of
government even though it actually
happened
and I'm gonna have to read directly from
the news article because I don't want to
miss any details it's such it's such a
crazy story this is from reading now
from a-z central and this is what it
says for nearly two decades at the Grand
Canyon
tourists employees and children on tour
passes tours and children on tours
passed by three paint buckets stored in
the national parks museum collection
building unaware that they are being
exposed to radiation although federal
officials learned last year that the
five gallon containers were brimming
with uranium ore then removed the
radioactive specimens the park safety
director alleges nothing was done to
warn Park workers on the public or the
public that they might have been exposed
to unsafe levels of radiation in a row
email sent to all Park Service employees
on February 4th
Elston Stephenson the safety health and
wellness manager described the alleged
cover-up as a quote top management
failure and warned of possible health
consequences he says if you were in the
museum collections building between the
year 2000
June 18th 2018 you were exposed to
uranium by OSHA's definition the reate
the radiation readings at first blush
exceed the nuclear regulatory commission
safe limits identifying who was exposed
and your exposure level gets tricky and
as our next important task according to
Stevenson the uranium specimens have
been in a basement at Park headquarters
for decades and were moved to museum to
the museum building when it opened
around 2000 one of the buckets was so
full that its lid would not close
Stevenson said the containers were
stored next to a taxidermy exhibit where
children on tours sometimes stopped for
presentations sitting next to uranium
for 30 minutes or more by his
calculation those children could have
received radiation dosages in excess of
federal safety standards within three
seconds and could have suffered
dangerous exposure in less than half a
minute and yet they were sitting next to
it for 30 minutes or more and the story
goes on goes on from there so the
National Park Service was storing
buckets of uranium in a museum next to
an exhibit where children would stop and
sit and nobody moved the Puckett's for
decades this is a I mean it's if you
don't know anything about the way
government works it gets it's
inconceivable
you just can't wrap your head around it
but this just shows how incompetent and
ineffectual of bureaucracy is that all
someone need to do needed to do was move
these buckets get rid of buckets and
something as simple as getting rid of
buckets literal buckets of uranium
something like that wasn't done for 20
years and keep something in mind that
there are people who want the government
to have complete control over our
healthcare system they want this
government that couldn't figure out how
to move buckets of uranium away from a
children's exhibit they want these
people to control our health care system
so just keep that
mind by the way something else that was
trending on social media yesterday along
with John Wayne actually someone else
was trending along with John Wayne and
that is Malia Obama Malia Obama of
course is Barack and Michelle's daughter
and I just want to mention this to you
in case you see stories about this
why was she trending well because
allegedly conservatives were outraged
that Malia Obama was drinking alcohol
there was a pictured apparently some
paparazzi person took pictures of Malia
Obama who was on a beach with her
friends somewhere drinking wine and
she's not 21 yet apparently I think
she's I think she's 20 which of course
who cares the fact that this woman who
is not a public figure not a politician
just a private citizen out on a beach
enjoying herself the fact that she was
drinking underage is of no concern to
anyone does not matter is not relevant
is not worthy of notice at all but if
you were on social media yesterday you
know you would have seen a lot of a lot
of liberals making this point and sag
well we would just just leave her alone
she's a private citizen just having a
drink what does it matter
and yeah that's that's true
but why were they making this point I
mean who were they arguing against who
actually disagrees what why is this even
a subject of conversation in the first
place well they claimed that
conservatives as I said were outraged
about Malia Obama drinking and so they
were defending her against conservative
outrage but so I saw this trending and I
and I kind of looked into and I said who
really what conservatives were mad about
who what kind of idiot on the
conservative side was making a big deal
out of this I gotta find these idiots
and so I looked and I checked and I
couldn't find any I could not find one
single conservative expressing any
outrage at all or any concern to any
degree about Malia Obama drinking wine
so there were a lot
people outraged about outrage that as
far as I could tell didn't exist so
what's going on with this well this is a
familiar tactic and we've seen it before
you may remember a few years ago the
when the media reported about a backlash
against Starbucks because their cups
weren't Christmassy enough you remember
that from a few years ago you probably
remember much more recently when that
video of Alexandria kzo Cortes dancing
on a roof and college went viral and the
media told us again that there was
backlash and conservatives were outraged
about the fact that she was dancing on a
roof and now we have this Malia Obama
thing what does all this have in common
well what it has in common is that
actually almost no conservatives really
cared about any of this the Starbucks
cup thing I remember they were like two
or three conservatives of relative sort
of prominence online who who who were
upset about the Starbucks cups and that
was those two or three people those two
or three silly people were taken and
extrapolated by the left into this whole
conservative backlash same thing with
Alexander okay occasional Cortese
dancing there were maybe a couple like a
small handful of conservatives on
Twitter or whatever who were making fun
of her because she danced on a roof
almost but everybody else didn't care
with all the rest of us were like who
cares fine it's a fun who cares about
this but they took that and they turned
it into they took those two or three
people and they turned it into a
conservatives are outraged but the
really impressive thing with this Malia
Obama thing is that you know at least
with Starbucks and with the dancing
video there were legitimately a couple
of conservatives who were concerned
about that and so they could take that
as sort of the the nucleus and then just
expand it but with Malia Obama I don't
think there was anybody I think that
they just invented this whole cloth they
invented this out of whole cloth they
just they just made this outrage appear
out of thin air based on absolutely
nothing
it is a
clever strategy though because the whole
point is to make us all make
conservatives look totally ridiculous
and simply for being concerned about
something like this when in fact none of
us were alright um want to get to some
of your emails you can email the show
Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt Walsh
Oh gmail.com with your comments
questions concerns hate mail a couple I
want to get through quickly this is from
a beardsman as how he signs his email it
says watching the show I've noted that
you were a professional looking
corporate beard corporate beards are
neat and all but I was wondering why did
you choose that instead of perhaps going
to terminal lengths or even just longer
than it is this isn't to shame you for
trimming but it is but it isn't a
terminal beard how God made you
especially a folically gifted as
folically gifted as you are I don't
understand why you would limit yourself
I guess the real question is why should
we cut our beards if we shouldn't shape
them on a somewhat related note how many
ways have you want a beard and how long
would you say you've been bearded I've
never been I've never heard this term
terminal beard before but I like it and
I'm couldn't use it a terminal beard
well I've been bearded I haven't been
clean-shaven in probably 15 years to
answer your your your last question but
I'll tell you here's the thing for me
the beardsman is that one of the great
advantages in my mind to having a beard
is is the is that it doesn't require a
lot of upkeep it's it laziness basically
that's part of the reason that I have a
beard and not just late well you know
what I won't even say business it's
about time management because if you
want to stay clean shave and it means
you're shaving every day and there's all
this effort that goes into it
and and you know I think studies have
shown that clean-shaven men by the time
they die they will have wasted
cumulatively they will have wasted two
and a half years of their life shaving
which is a statistic that I basically
made up but maybe it's true and it's
just
total waste of time you know that time
would be better spent doing other things
but the problem is when you grow the
beard really long if you get it too long
then you end up almost you're back at
the beginning and now it requires a lot
of upkeep like if you want to grow your
beard long and not look like Tom Hanks
from cast away then it required you know
you've got a you've got to do a lot of
trimming and it requires other things to
make it actually look like a good beard
and not like you're you know some kind
of some kind of vagrant or whatever so
my strategy is I'll just have the beard
and I don't do anything with it I let it
grow and then everyone so I'll just trim
it back to about this length and I'll
let it grow again and that's the way
that that's just a it's just the way to
maximize or to be as efficient as
possible I guess that's that's why I
have it like this this is from Jeremy
says hey Matt if leftist believes so
strongly in a victim hierarchy wouldn't
they have to put the unborn at the top
it's completely absurd to grant a
special victim status to gays
transgenders minorities and women while
simultaneously promoting the active
genocide of children up until and after
birth if they truly cared about victims
ending abortion should be their top
priority well Jeremy I totally agree of
course but you see the the the
difference is that although unborn the
unborn children are victims in our
culture and they are a group of people
who cannot fend for themselves and need
to be defended the problem from the left
perspective is that you know an unborn
child represents a sacrifice a personal
sacrifice that you have to make to care
for and love this child and part of
leftism is that you shouldn't you
shouldn't have to make sacrifices that
your life is all about you it's all
about your own enjoyment your own
pleasure using your own money for
yourself that's the point of life as far
as they're concerned and unborn children
interfere with that which is why they
have to be discarded but you know as far
as their good like defending gays and
minorities and women well sure I mean
it's because that that doesn't interfere
with em at all so that's easy but an
unborn child is something different all
right finally this is this is from
Breanna she says hey Matt recently a
parenting counselor came to speak to
some moms at my church and it became
obvious pretty quickly that she was an
advocate for positive parenting she said
we should never give timeouts or
punishments of any kind and that we
should only be talking through the
situation while acknowledging the
child's feelings she also had science
and research to back up her parenting
views citing some sources although I
admittedly haven't looked through them
yet what is your view on positive
parenting and do you think it works
Breanna I'm not really familiar with
that phrase but if positive parenting is
what you describe namely no punishments
of any kind no discipline that I think
it's madness and I really don't care
what research she brings to the table I
mean you have to keep in mind here that
parenting is a very complex kind of
thing that is to parent well to parent
successfully is is complex and dynamic
and it's not possible to really measure
in a study so the primary job of a
parent is to is to instill virtue in a
child so these studies about parenting
how do they measure virtue in order to
determine what kind of parenting is best
what is the virtue memory measuring tool
where they could say this type of
parenting instills 12.5 percent more
virtue than this other kind
it's obviously absurd the problem with
all these parenting studies and the
research and the parenting strategies
and the parenting books and everything
else is that it treats parenting like a
science when
it's really not it's it's more of an art
but it's bigger than that even it's a
relation it's a human relationship right
and human relationships cannot be
condensed down in this way they can't be
poked and prodded in a laboratory so the
studies don't mean anything I don't care
about them
the idea of parenting without punishment
is is crazy for two reasons number one
the children need limits they need
boundaries this is one of the one of the
primary things that a child needs child
needs to be told no this is about giving
direction this is this is one of the
main things that a child looks to a
parent for and so if the parent says
well I'm not gonna give you that I'm
only going to affirm I'm gonna be a
positive but I'm only gonna say yes well
then you are depriving your child of of
a need of a necessity and something else
to keep in mind secondly is that yeah
you may have a positive parenting style
but the world does not so the real world
is not going to be positive all the time
when your child goes out into the world
and gets a job his boss is not probably
not going to have a positive management
style where he only tells his employees
yes and only affirms them positively and
only says nice things nobody in the
world is gonna have that strategy you
know nobody else will that's not the way
the world operates so if you raise your
child in an environment where they're
only ever affirmed ever and they're only
told positive things and they're never
told no and they're never punished and
they never face consequences and they
never face discipline then you are
preparing them for a world that doesn't
exist you may as well instead of
teaching them how to drive a car you may
as well teach them how to
a unicorn because it's the same exact
thing you are giving them a uu art
you're preparing them for something that
doesn't exist
that's one of the reasons why a child
needs to be taught about boundaries and
needs to be given discipline and needs
to be told no because he's gonna live
the rest of his life in a world that
tells him no and a world that has
boundaries and a world where there is
consequences and where there are
punishments sometimes very severe ones
if you if you screw up so this I
wouldn't be I would be listening to this
woman in her parenting strategies and I
would also be suspicious of this church
if this is the kind of parenting lesson
that the church endorses because I'll
say something else this also certainly
is not biblical parenting spare the rod
spoil the child right that's what the
that's what the Bible says all right
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed